ma è vitale ma pensa davvero che sia
nascosto lì c'è qualcosa guerra finestra
dal castello chi si nasconde per primo e
nasconditi tu per prima così io magari
posso andare alla ricerca di cibo così
magari se ci prendono possiamo avere del
cibo nelle segrete pensare un attimo
queste notti nascondi tutto
così almeno so che non sarei andato a
cercare cibo borden vai inizia
nasconderti fino a quanto dovrò contare
conto fino al 30 12 chiba
mi stavo dimenticando che devo cercare
vitale ok iniziamo a cercarlo perdevo di
riuscire a trovarlo presto e di non
dover girare il castello da sola
inquietante girare questo castello da
sola forse era questo il piano del re
fin dall'inizio separarci e farci stare
da soli vediamo se qua sopra dove si era
nascosto
qui non c'è nessuno la giuso il castello
dove dei ti troverò per sé nel cast
vediamo vista
ho sentito un amore l'avete sentito
è una statua non è vitale o no non
riesco a trovarlo se fosse stato preso
da qualcuno
devo pensare vitale dove si
nasconderebbe pitali si nasconderebbe
dove c'è il cibo quindi porta è
rientrato da solo dentro al castello
fisso qualcosa ha nessun valore là sopra
vediamo se promuovere qua anche se avevo
già controllato ma
ma c'è qualcosa là dietro
oggi credo vitale ti ho trovato chi ha
trovato meno spazio che viene detto da
bravissimo trovarmi si era fatto
debuttare 1234567 dove stai andando a 89
vicenda dei tre fratelli sensi tetti che
ravetti che trovi 32 34 c per i 730 deve
cercare lì io so dove sia nascosta
sicuramente è andata nel roseto
perché la vita allora le rose quindi
andiamo a vedere per prima cosa nel
roseto
adoro questo e clicchiamo inferiore del
giardino e qui mi sembra di vedere
nell'unità poi fatemi sapere se lo
vedete sono quasi sicuro che l'inter
nascosta
allora
questo è il roseto però non la vedo che
queste saranno da qualche altra parte
ma
ho visto qualcosa muoversi dietro quell
albero
sì sì se provo qualcosa che si muove di
euro quell'albero andiamo andiamo a
controllare più da vicino ma perché
proprio dietro quell albero
adesso la spaventiamo perché siamo
bravissimo nascondimi stare ferma quando
giochi a nascondino non puoi fare rumore
non mi ha fatto vedere il mio ospiti di
oggi oggi ho una magliettina celeste con
i cuori neri e una gonnellina nera vi
piace quest'estate sono inquietanti
sembra che mi osservino realmente
comunque devo puntare 22 30
andiamo alla ricerca di vitale si fanno
meditare e sceso di un giardino così ma
quello ma è vitale ma pensa davvero che
sia nascosto lì d'azione meno nascosto
si vede benissimo soprattutto con quella
maglietta gialla che è andato lì vabbè
andiamo a prenderlo come se io non lo
vedessi
riscattando che ti ho già preso evitare
sta scappando ma io l'ho già visto
quindi ha già perso non sembra che lui
scappino stesse confuso sul gioco a cui
stiamo giocando vitale male che ti ho
già visto pensi di essere invisibile
certo non ti stacchi nemmeno nascosto
really rannicchiato perché mi sei mezzo
lino pensavo che funzionasse la magia
dell'invisibilità no in realtà mi sono
messo lì perché c'è la porta della
cucina è finito spettatori è uscito un
co.co.co si potesse fare
non ci credo ti sei messo lì solo perché
c'è la cucina in effetti non è questo il
momento di mantenere la challenge
altrimenti il re si arrabbierà tocca a
me nascondermi 7
[Musica]
nel frattempo che cerco il mio
nascondiglio è stato un po guardando gli
alberi perché io adoro gli alberi sono
bellissimi hanno tutto questo libro è un
po strano guardate posto dentro dopo mai
visto un albero così magari contiene
qualche segreto dentro qualche abitante
che arrivano albero magico guarda qua
guarda anche questo ramo è molto
particolare
davvero bello questo albero adoro gli
altri che ha ricomposto palette un sang
altro di tanto il castello promuovo semi
terra guarda ti ricordi di quel terrazzo
dove avevi visto qualcosa di strano mia
biglietto certo come lo ricordo pure
paura vabbè meglio che ci sbrighiamo
perché sta facendo buio è meglio non
giocare a nascondino al buio ok ragazzi
per nascondermi penso che l'ultimo turno
ho deciso di farlo un po difficile
nessuno
queste sono le mura del castello
guardate c'è del tipo corridoio fatto di
piante bellissimo amiamo qua vediamo
cosa c'è speriamo di non perderci
[Musica]
quasi una torre del castello
queste sono le mura del castello ai dati
cappello
[Musica]
guardate
trattori nascondiglio perfetto questo
nascondiglio perfetto trovato il
nascondiglio perfetto questo corridoio
del castello
guardate la dietro se il castello
secondo me vitale non mi troverò mai
vinsero la challenge e secondo voi chi
vincerà
e ora aspettiamo e speriamo che scada il
tempo
cambiamo aria del castello adesso
vediamo se anita si è nascosta qui da
qualche parte qui in effetti ci sono
degli ottimi nascondigli e son sicuro
che anita si sia nascosta proprio qui
magari a qua dietro ma che proprio
nascosta ma questa torre
la donna della vedetta no sembra proprio
che non sia qui continuiamo a cercarla
qualità dove sei
si sia nascosta proprio dietro la grande
muraglia del castello
andiamo a controllare quest'altro torre
magari è proprio qui che si nasconde
e no non si nasconde neanche qui adesso
sta pure diventando buio mi devo
sbrigare passato è troppo distratto
pensare al cibo si è accorto che sono in
questo corridoio
ci credete niente mi sa che il tempo è
scaduto
quindi posso uscire dal mio amico e di
ricche aperto a 20
dove
dove ti dico di sì
dico la mia vita ho vinto
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa che cos'è secondo
guardato vero nascosta il giornalino
della torretta sei passato con questo
significa solo una cosa o pinto la salle
e ora dovrei ricevere un vestito reale
investito reale nel senso che non è
virtuale al reale lincoln senza ora
forse è meglio che torniamo perché si
sta facendo buio
ci sono varie cose alle finestre del
castello e vero facciamo la sala del
rito assieme se c'è qualcosa di strano
lo vedrete in cui voi siete già
[Musica]
bellissimo gente non ti sporgere troppo
che sono i casi in qualche buco ma
smentito
ecco il terrazzino da cui vitale aveva
visto qualcuno ok queste sono le nostra
scala
[Musica]
non c'è altro
c'era chiuso fuori
chissà perché
guarda io se questo guarda c'è il
simbolo del lupo o meglio del re però
non era argentato lettura fatto forse il
premio per aver vinto la challenge
silvia voti di sinistra plichi è un
vestito reale come diceva nella lettera
sembra bellissimo
vediamo perché bellissimo cosa c'è di
che cos'è le maniche una manica fine non
mi sento un utile da ma del castello era
una battuta ha fatto già pezzi il
vestito non è che vorrà fare a pezzi a
chiedere tanto maglietta no no no ma è
bellissimo
a voi piace questo vestito secondo voi
dovrei provarlo lasciati un mi piace se
volete che mi provi il mio nuovo vestito
reale prendere in giro per il castello
con questo vestito da damigella via e
sono poggio rosso però che il red abbia
fatto questo regalo
non devi essere geloso in bellissimo
vestito sei geloso perché se il mio
fidanzato
ma no sono geloso perché il renon ha
regalato anche a me ha un bel vestito
magari una bella armatura da cavaliere
patteggia mosso solo per quello non mi
hai detto nemmeno 3 ti piace questo
vestito
mi starebbe bene si è molto bello questo
vestito però ricordati che questo
vestito lontana regalato il re è
praticamente tu hai vinto questo vestito
perché io non ti ho trovato è quindi se
io non ti ho trovato da chi ovviamente
questo vestito come se avesse regalato
io eh vabbè poi lasciato mi piace se
volete che mi provo un pesto belli
sentito e nel prossimo episodio lo
proverò la destra la prossima challenge
del resto non c'è nessuna lettera e la
prossima lettera sicuramente dovremo
trovarla ma dove
[Musica]